well let's return to our breaking news
that the International Criminal Court is
preparing to investigate alleged war
crimes in the Palestinian territories
Turek to recap the ICC's chief
prosecutor says this could include
charges against Israelis or Palestinians
fireburn Souter says she's satisfied
that war crimes have been or are
currently being committed in the West
Bank including East Jerusalem and the
Gaza Strip but Israel's Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu says the court has no
jurisdiction to investigate inside the
Palestinian territories well let's take
you to Twitter where Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu has said the
investigation would quote turn the
tribunal into a political weapon against
Israel and against our country we want
to turn Jews living in their homeland
into war crimes
it's absurd in every possible way well
at this point we can speak to Alma
hijazi who's the assistant minister from
Minister for multilateral affairs for
the state of Palestine he's also a
member of the Palestinian mission to the
UN and he joins us live from Ramallah
via Skype thank you for being with us
sir I'm going to start by asking you
about what Israel is saying that there
is no jurisdiction for the ICC to
investigate here what is your response
that's a sole opinion the international
community and everybody else and all
international and relevant international
bodies have determined that there is
jurisdiction for international law or
international courts and for human
rights law and that they are all
applicable to the occupied Palestinian
territory and Israel is the only country
in this world that does not recognize
these facts and if they can continue
claiming that but it will not change the
fact that those laws and those norms do
apply to the occupied Palestinian
territory and they cannot escape this
fact let me ask you mr. hijazi because I
understand that Palestine referred this
to the International Criminal Court the
possibility that war crimes were being
committed now back in May and so why do
you think it's taken quite so long to
get to this point
well actually the whole case started
more than five years ago and we were
always wondering why it took them
to open investigations and to start in
the process of investigations given that
the crimes that Israel has been
committing on in the occupied
Palestinian territory are very obvious
including the crime of the transfer of
its own citizens into the occupied
Palestinian territory which is a war
crime under their own statute that has
been noticed by the Palestinian
government but nonetheless we will come
this as a first step forward in order to
grant the victims of those crimes
justice as soon as possible and to bring
them punished what are you hoping to
achieve here you're talking about trying
to fight for justice but in terms of
actual concrete measures I mean that
this investigation could take some time
what are you actually hoping to see out
of the ICC well we're hoping that the
ICC will hold those who are committing
crimes against our people against our
land and the crimes that are outlined in
the Rome Statute accountable to their
crimes and that no more crimes are being
committed on the Palestinian land which
will basically set the stage for ending
occupation and thus opening the path for
a conclusion of this conflict otherwise
if Israel continues to conduct its
crimes on our land without any with
impunity and without any accountability
we believe that this conflict will be
perpetuated forever and there is no
solution to it so the court and its role
it will provide peace to this land
revolving those criminals and those who
allow for these crimes to be committed
in the occupied Palestinian territory
accountable to their hands so from what
you're saying there sir you're saying
that you view this this entire ICC
investigation whatever happens next as
part of a peace process well it is part
of justice to the Palestinian people
this process was intended to achieve
justice the Palestinian people and just
this is what we seek what we seek is an
end to the oppression duda tyranny that
is being exerted and
to the punishments and and to the
violations of human rights and and
rights of Palestinian people left and
right by the Israeli government with
with no one holding it accountable at a
national level or an international level
discord was established to to hold
accountable those who committed the most
violent of crimes that choke you in the
International humanity a humanity
conscience accountable to their crimes
so we believe that justice is what we
see and we hope that justice is what we
what prevail then let me ask you one
more question mr. Hijazi beyond the idea
of justice and people would say well
some people would argue that
international justice is I guess a less
tactile less tangible thing for people
on the ground than perhaps a state what
are you hoping to get out of this in
terms of concrete measures for people in
the Palestinian territories concrete
measures is accountability holding
Israel accountable to its crimes meaning
that ending all violations that are
being committed ending the expansion of
settlement and ending the theft of land
and in the destruction of homes ending
the kill the killing of our children
without anyone being held accountable
those are the concrete measures that we
hope to hold and and all of these
together will grant a sense of justice
the Palestinian people and that someone
out there cares about their faith and
that someone is paying a price for
violations committed against them this
is the truth of the matter and
difference Israel continues to have a
free hand in committing these crimes
without being held accountable there is
no hope in achieving neither peace nor
any future of ending this conflict
I'm a hijazi there the Assistant
Minister for multilateral affairs for
the state of Palestine thank you sir for
joining us on al-jazeera
thank you